no habrá semifinal de Roland garros para
Tomás Echeverría el argentino perdió su
partido ante Alexander es bereb en tres
horas y 22 horas de juego y cuatro sets
con parciales de seis cuatro tres seis
seis tres y seis a cuatro pero hay que
decir que el argentino peleó bastante a
lo largo de todo este partido se de
hecho se hizo con el público del Philips
primera vez que el argentino además
jugaba uno partido en la cancha central
de rolana de arroz y bueno también puso
en dificultades algunas veces al alemán
Especialmente cuando varió el juego y lo
sacó de esa rutina que impones bereb de
pelotas muy largas en el fondo de la
cancha sin embargo es Pues tiene un
servicio muy poderoso y además también
la experiencia y un poco más de
precisión que el argentino ahora pues el
Alemán va a disputar su tercera
semifinal por tercer año consecutivo
aquí en Roland garros está esperando
saber cuál será su contrincante eso va a
definirse esta noche en el último
partido que ha de disputarse hoy será
entre holgueros uno y cáspera Ruth esos
eran los últimos el último partido de
cuartos de final Y pues o sea por ahora
es Beatriz Maya quien es la única
latinoamericana que queda en alisa la
brasileña que hoy sorprendió tras vencer
a monser la número siete del mundo y
ahora la brasileña que va a medirse a
higas Brian tecla número uno del mundo
en la semifinal que va a disputarse el
día de mañana